hey guys I think today we are going to
do something super super special I am
going to be making custom Madeline's
with my favorite Baker in the world and
that is why we are here at Dominique
Ansel kitchen so Dominique Ansel bakery
actually gets these huge lines in the
morning so apart from making my own
custom flavor we're actually going to be
giving out these Madeline's tomorrow
bright and early
let's go hi everyone I'm chef Dominique
Ansel we're here in New York City at
Dominique Ansel kitchen I've been a
pastry chef for over 25 years now I love
baking I love creating new things today
I'm doing something special with Inga
and much' Madeline they are like the
small pillow he takes the delicious and
we're gonna make a special version today
which is with Masha okay so you're gonna
do it and like a [ __ ] I am so excited
my mom loves baking she used to make
these marshmallows that I am obsessed as
much as I love my shuttle really yes yes
almost every morning so it's this very
simple recipe really the only trick is
that you have to make it the day before
this baking powder in a recipe which
need to rest for at least 6 to 12 hours
you're gonna cook today hey I'm not
doing anything
it's pretty boring parts are gonna heat
up the pot in medium heat what we're
gonna do is essentially melt the butter
and then we're going to add the brown
sugar so the reason why we had the brown
sugar with the butter is actually to
melt the brown sugar and then a little
bit of honey so it's to flavor the
Madeline is actually very nice I love
and we're gonna heat this up just enough
to melt everything together
more look bad not bad that's the French
reps it's good well it's not bad
whatever sits good amazing we don't say
anything
it's just good why this is melting we're
gonna make the rest of ingredients doing
outside with the flour boom that's it
and then I'll my cha powder my favourite
little sugar I love it
then we have a little bit of salt yes
exactly and very important the baking
powder and we're gonna put this on the
mixer there's no need to mix it very
fast it's just really like combined
together we have a few eggs here that
we're gonna add so this recipe is really
really easy but the people are super
impressed because they're super
impressed because it's fresh to me how's
it looking this is good it's just like
multi then combined together
smells already a base here with all the
dry ingredients and the eggs is finally
mixed and the last part about the fat
and this boy with the inside this is a
little bit dangerous I got you yes I
feel like okay just slowly slowly
there we go that's good good time okay
so we're looking for like a very smooth
batter that has no this is a flower you
won't have any lumps here
that's beautiful that's it you're not
even hurt yourself everything just makes
beautiful I love the karate Oh beautiful
green and we're gonna put this in a
piping bag we'll place it in a fridge
for about 12 hours
I made one ahead of time someone can
type them together I mean I could also
camp out here for 24 hour and I'm okay
we're gonna feed our people in ninety
one morning people waiting for us to
open the shop so every morning our baked
fresh Madeline's just to welcome
everyone for woody we're gonna give this
one out to the people tomorrow yes
exactly I hope they'll like it I hope
you like it I was waiting for you to say
it no I'm sure they'll like it like you
love it bye delenn for the line male
infant line so this is a Madeleine pan
those are mini Madeline's I like the
smaller size because it's just one or
two bites and they make much much faster
I spray a little bit and then we have
our manly barrow that is rested for 12
hours and then we're just going to pipe
it so right here about like 3/4 of the
way you're gonna do it - I'm gonna make
one and you're gonna make one
all yours now
show me watch gotcha that's a different
style whereas their walk so what you
want a lot of constancy today all the
same size it's a little bit too much
stuff let me show you I place one hand
on top one hand right here closer to the
chip so I squeeze it so I control the
pressure that's the most important press
and you can hear you press to get it
here there you go that's better see if
it gets you so much faster early much
more consistent that's it yes we're
gonna bake this in the oven at 375
degrees it's easy right you do like this
they rise so beautiful yes so that's the
specific shape of madam the top of melon
what I call the pearl I think most
beautiful part of your mother this is
yours can you tell let's just they have
their own personality that's cute
be proud that you're different you must
hide this one
investigated
destroy evidence destroy them happy so
the way we serve it at the bakery we
grab them while this hot piping hot
we're gonna finish it with a little bit
of my shop sugar and a little bit of
matcha powder just on top that's Alex so
for me I wouldn't ride then just Cheers
it's so fluffy they like it's wrong he
was going to love it you morning I can't
wait I will see you bright and early
tomorrow morning
[Music]
are you good today well good and then
this one you said yeah Paul she's gonna
take your job maybe maybe I don't know
that's good no faster oh my god I don't
know if my hands are sweaty or like okay
it's okay
I've seen better now we wait for minutes
David is so fun
all right let's do it Toby yeah they're
gonna be very happy very excited good
morning big one we have a special guest
today that made a special treat for you
we're fun messy and we made a special
flavour with chef Dominique please enjoy
this hot chocolate for that know it's so
nerve-racking I wish I did better today
this morning
under pressure from more Latino content
right here
[Music]